hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes in which I recapped most
ravishing language and ideas on the last
week of Wired first up today mother
issues and auto Pia's coverage of the
SpaceX launch to the International Space
Station officials were sent to welcome
the cooperation of Mother Nature but why
mother why not father nature or second
cousin once removed or creepy uncle it's
because your mother loves you unless
you're Kevin from home alone in which
case your mother finds you to be
entirely forgettable the word nature
itself derives from the Latin meaning
birth we personify nature as a mother
because she not only creates us she
provides for us father time however
reminds us of our own mortality and then
if we're not home by ten we'll get
grounded the maternal personification of
nature is extremely common across world
cultures from the Maori to the ancient
Greeks we can actually trace the
nurturing mother theme back even farther
to 25,000 years ago when Paleolithic
peoples carved Kirby female figurines
that suggest bounty and fertility some
anthropologists believe these figurines
represent mother goddesses some students
failing intro to anthropology believe
these were just stones that fell into a
ravine and coincidentally got shipped
that way but like any good mom mother
nature can be intimidating at times 18th
century philosopher Edmund Burke argued
that the sublime a true aesthetic
greatness occurs when natural monuments
instill terror in us consider things
like epic mountain ranges in trees
shaped like middle fingers and the most
sublime of mountain ranges the fabled
mrs. Everest who comes after you with a
soup ladle if you don't wipe your feet
at base camp next up Fear and Loathing
in Greece under wire report on a new
e-book on the Greek financial crisis
done in the gonzo style
rhymes in the chorus no not that gonzo
the hunter s thompson version so what is
gonzo it's hundreds Thompson's brand of
journalism that shuns objectivity
written the first person by a reporter
on the ground it's like Fox News only
grounded in reality in 1970 a boston
globe editor was the first to use the
word gonzo to describe Thompson's work
saying that there were several
definitions of it in South Boston slang
for instance gonzo can refer to the last
man standing in a group drinking binge
though he can call himself whatever he
wants on account of everybody else being
unconscious comptons premier gonzo work
is fear and loathing in las vegas in
which he and a samoan lawyer hit to Sin
City to cover a motorcycle race end up
getting debilitatingly high on things
other than motorcycle exhaust this
lawyers name was in fact dr. gonzo and
was based on Thompson's friend Oscar
Zetas a Costa an attorney and activist
according to Thompson a Costa was a
menace who always had a 357 Magnum in
his belt and a hatchet wielding
bodyguard at his side which happens to
be my ammo Thompson's gonzo style
proliferate stood a especially among
bloggers who do things like take acid
and go to things you shouldn't go to on
drugs while their mothers sit at home
and wish they'd hit their children more
often with soup ladles
you